PROFESSOR: So,
adiabatic results.
So last time we just
followed and tried
to use an instantaneous
eigenstate
to construct the solution
of the Schrodinger equation.
Our result was that
we couldn't quite
construct the solution of
the Schrodinger equation.
What we wrote didn't exactly
solve the Schrodinger equation.
But we claimed that it was
important and interesting.
And therefore let me
remind you of what we said.
So we showed that the
wave function, psi of t,
could be written as a constant
here, e to the i theta of t, e
to the i gamma of t
times this wave function.
And that wave
function here was what
we called an instantaneous
eigenstate of the Hamiltonian.
So H of t acting on psi of t
was, at any instant of time,
an eigenstate.
Nevertheless, we said that
these eigenstates are not
solutions of the Schrodinger
equation in general.
They solve this funny time--
inspired by the time-independent
Schrodinger equation,
this instantaneous
eigenstate condition.
But when you try to solve
the Schrodinger equation,
this psi of t
would not solve it.
So we tried to
add things, and we
constructed what seemed
to be close to a solution.
And there it is.
What was theta of t?
It was a dynamical
phase, it's called,
and is defined by this integral.
If E of t was a constant, it
would be a minus E times t
over H bar.
And this would be the
familiar phase with which
you evolve energy eigenstates.
The second term, this gamma of
t, was a little more intricate.
We define an
intermediate thing called
nu of t, which was i
times the inner product
of the instantaneous
eigenstate with the derivative
with respect to time of the
instantaneous eigenstate.
We argued that this factor
over here was imaginary.
Therefore we put an
i so that nu is real.
And the gamma of t-- so
these were definitions.
It's defined as 0 to t
dt prime nu of t prime.
OK.
So the claim was
that if you happen
to have a wave function
that, at time equals 0,
it's in one of those
instantaneous eigenstates,
it would remain in such
instantaneous eigenstate up
to phases that are calculable.
OK.
So let's make this a
little more explicit,
in the sense of an
adiabatic theorem.
So I'll also put here that
this is not an exact solution.
So I would say the
wave function at time t
is roughly given
by that quantity.
It's not exactly, because
it's not an exact solution
of the Schrodinger equation.
So if we want to state the
adiabatic theorem a little more
precisely, we consider a set
of instantaneous eigenstates.
Instantaneous eigenstates.
And that is H of t psi n of
t equal E n of t psi n of t.
And here n will go from 1
up to possibly infinity.
It just doesn't have to stop.
It can go on forever.
OK.
Equipped with the
instantaneous eigenstates,
you might decide
that you initially
want to be in a state.
So psi at t equals 0
is given by psi K at 0.
That's your initial condition.
Now, you look at
this and say, OK,
when is the adiabatic
result that you're
going to stay roughly in
that energy eigenstate going
to be true?
This is going to require
that, as you have the energy E
K as a function of time--
here is the energy E K
as a function of time.
0.
So I'll write it here.
You should have that
this doesn't get mixed,
or doesn't coincide,
with some other energy,
like something like
that, the crossing,
or that they touch
with another one.
You should keep them separate.
You know that the
general perturbation
theory makes life complicated.
And if you find another
state that gets very close,
the adiabatic theorem or
the adiabatic approximation
might go wrong.
So we want other
energy eigenstates.
Here is E K minus 1,
and here is E K plus 1.
So you have all these
energy eigenvalues
as a function of time.
And you want that,
for example, E K--
you order all your energies,
and you want that E K of t
is definitely less
than E K plus 1
of t, which is less than
or equal to the other ones.
And this is definitely
greater than E K minus 1
of t, which is greater or
equal than the other one.
So the instantaneous
energy eigenstates
that you are focused in
should be well separated
from the other ones.
Otherwise you could
run into difficulties.
So that's definitely
necessary for this to hold.
Then the adiabatic
theorem says that psi of t
will be approximately
equal to e to the i theta
K of t, e to the i gamma
K of t times psi K of t.
So I'm keeping a little
difference of notation,
trying to be careful.
These wave functions, at all
times, I put them with a line
below the psi.
And these instantaneous energy
eigenstates, I don't put that.
So a little difference that
should help you determine this.
Now, what are these
theta K or gamma K?
Are just the same quantities.
I might as well write
them for completeness.
Theta K of t is
what you had before.
Minus 1 over H bar 0 to t.
But this time E
K of the t prime.
Then you have nu of t.
Nu K is equal to i psi
K of t psi K dot of t.
And finally the gamma K of
t is the integral from 0
to t of nu of t prime dt
prime K. Everything with K,
corresponding to
the Kth eigenstate.
So this is a more
precise version
already of the statement of
the adiabatic approximation.
You want to make it
even more precise?
We'll say something about
the error in this formula.
In a sense, the hard work in
the adiabatic approximation
is telling you how
much error there is.
So we will not go through
proof of the error.
We'll just motivate it.
And perhaps this will be
discussed in recitation.
It's an interesting
subject, and goes back
to work of Born, Max
Born, the one that
gave the probabilistic
interpretation of quantum
mechanics, and Fock,
of Fock space states
of the harmonic oscillator.
They did the first
work doing that.
Then a Japanese fellow,
Kato, in the middle '50s--
so Born and Fock
was 1928, I believe.
And in the '50s, Kato
improved the analysis
of the adiabatic theorem.
And this whole thing
has many applications
to the theory of molecules
and spin states and systems.
We will begin to see
some of this today.
And had the big revival
with the discovery of Berry
that there's quite a lot
of physics in this phase.
This phase here--
this is a normal phase
that you know for
energy eigenstates,
slightly generalized.
But this phase is
very different.
And that's what Barry
elaborated and explained
and showed that it could be
observable in some cases.
And it was a pretty
nice discovery.
So basically, the
adiabatic statement here
says that you don't jump to
another instantaneous energy
eigenstate, you remain in
that instantaneous energy
eigenstate.
OK.
Another thing that is important
is that sometimes you say,
well, these are phases.
When you have states,
the phases are
unobservable over all
phases of a state.
You calculate the
state after a while.
It has a phase.
Well, that phase of
your physical state
doesn't make any difference.
Well, that's true.
The overall phase of a state
doesn't make any difference.
But if you have a system that
is in a superposition of two
quantum states,
one corresponding
to one instantaneous
energy eigenstate and one
corresponding to another--
so there's psi equal to psi
1 and psi 2, one for each--
psi 1, by the linearity
of quantum mechanics,
is going to develop
its own phase.
Psi 2 is going to
develop its own phase.
And now the relative
phase is observable.
When you have a
superposition of states,
the relative phase
is observable.
And therefore, if the two states
evolve with different phases,
you can have observable
consequences.
So there is something
that can happen here,
and something that
can be measured.